well what we're going to do is allow
butchers in um abattoirs and meat
processors dealing with pigs to be able
to come in on a temporary basis under
the seasonal workers scheme for up to
six months and that will help us to deal
with the backlogs of pigs that we
currently have on farm give those meat
processors the ability to
slaughter more pigs and crucially as
well we're going to make available
what's called private storage aid to
help those abattoirs to temporarily
store that meat
in order to help clear this backlog
before they can release it to market
let's get more with our chief political
correspondent john craig and john i
suppose the question is will this do the
job will it help you know avoid these
culls
well mr eustis was only talking about
800 people coming over under this
temporary visa scheme uh which doesn't
sound that many when you think for
example that when it came to
temporary visas for poultry workers it
was five thousand five hundred and for
hgv drivers five thousand six months
well okay that's uh uh perhaps longer
than uh perhaps we we imagined but
crucially what the government has
rejected
is the call for relaxing the rules on uh
people coming over having decent having
good english um and that was one thing
that was being demanded uh the english
language retirement requirement for a
meat processing workers uh was being
called for by the industry mr eustace
says they've rejected that now that
scheme he's just mentioned uh the
private storage aid
basically that provides some funding
for farmers for slaughtered pigs to be
held in private cold stores uh and that
was something that uh the
industry was calling for in a meeting
with sir dave lewis now he is the former
tesco boss who is now the government
supply chain czar if you like
and so they will be pleased about that
so clearly the government has moved and
given the industry some of the things
that they wanted but not the english
language uh relaxation so uh
we there will be com claims no doubt
that the visas will take time to process
there will probably be complaints this
is all too slow that it should have been
done earlier
mr eustis was talking about how in fact
they had been talking to the industry
for some time
so he's made his decision now
there will be those who say that it's
not enough but he has bowed to some
other pressure and
perhaps the slaughter of a hundred and
fifty thousand uh pigs are being
destroyed and in some cases incinerated
perhaps in a rather cruel way that the
government will hope has been avoided
and
the government will hope that perhaps
this is one problem in the supply chain
crisis that perhaps they have found at
least a partial solution to